in 2011 Jonathan che co-founder of
irrational games established a new indie
studio named Blu Manchu among its
members were several veterans of the
iconic Looking Glass Studios and its
mission statement was to make innovative
strategy games titles the developers
themselves would love to play in an
interview with Gamasutra che called them
nishijin regimes the team's first
release was card hunter which combined
the systems of a deck building title
with the mechanics of a tabletop board
game in many respects it was the exact
kind of project you'd expect from the
studio it's sleek it's focused and it
falls well within the nishijin resume
and shoe set out to toy with but now we
have void Basterds the team's sophomore
effort and a drastic departure from its
indeed a PU
unlike card hunter it does not focus on
one or two Nicias but a slew of them
it's a genre chameleon bouncing between
categories at a breakneck pace it defies
any simple labels and it is fantastic
because of it
owing to the way it's so effortlessly
jumps between genres Boyd masters is
extremely difficult to classify in one
sentence but let's give it a try this is
a sci-fi strategy shooter with roguelike
elements and immersive sim complexity
even now there are things I couldn't get
across in that description the way void
Basterds stresses stealth for instance
without really telling you it's a
stealth game or how its shooting
elements have a throwback feel to them
harkening back to its software's glory
days on 90s pcs or even though I permit
death forces you from one character to
the next granting you different
personality traits recalling the
ancestry system of rogue legacy or the
more recent prey moon crash DLC it's
important to note that void Basterds
isn't an example of the kitchen sink
approach it's not like raged to the
open-world shooter that feels like two
completely separate games it doesn't add
mechanics or mash systems together just
to extend its features list here
everything has a purpose take this
mission for example I'm about 15 hours
into the game at this point with myriad
upgrades that have carried over from
previous
characters my current protagonist Murphy
is in a tough situation
because of Murphy's numerous upgrades
and weapons I was able to skip over a
handful of early missions unless I
needed food fuel or other essential
items I was content to breeze toward the
more difficult heists featuring more
powerful enemies and of course more
useful loop because of Murphy's
infiltrator characteristic I could see
that this medical ship would be full of
enemies called Zechs I can also see that
the power would be off on arrival these
simple facts that I would be boarding a
powered down medical ship full of
shielded enemies told me a lot they
influenced my equipment loadout I opted
to bring proximity mines to get behind
those ex shields they influence how much
food I ate before boarding seeing is how
it was a medical ship I could recover
health without digging into my personal
sandwich supply and finally they
influenced my actual route through the
ship with the power off I would need to
head to the generator first or miss out
on numerous loot caches behind
electronic clocks but not only does void
bastards potent mix of strategy shooting
and role-playing affect my planning and
also of course affects the execution of
that plan and in void Basterds the gap
between planning and execution is a mile
wide I might be planning a quiet
sneaking mission through a specific set
of corridors but oftentimes that will
devolve into frantic improvisation when
a security camera detects me and
activates a powerful security Buy and I
don't have the ability to hack it yet so
I spend the rest of the mission trying
to get to the security center to
deactivate the bots and his friends but
instead I end up surrounded by Zechs and
I come this close to dying and moving to
the next character but instead I make it
to the airlock with almost no loot and
even less health then I breathe a sigh
and I plan for the next thrilling
mission all of this is to say that it's
refreshing to play a game that
understands how John Rose can complement
one another I already mentioned the
harsh dichotomy of rage too but this
feature clash is an epidemic in modern
game design titles such as days gone
Kingdom Hearts 3 or Far Cry new dawn
while fine in their own rights often
have
celeriac tivities that don't always
figure into the game's overarching
identities avoid bastards though has
almost no fat whatsoever it's quote
unquote back of the box features list is
extensive but not at all excessive to
use Jonathan Shay's earlier quote he and
his team have made a genre game but
ironically it is not an issue it runs
the gamut from classic shooters to
immersive role-playing games and there
are qualities here that many people will
like but void Basterds does not pander
it's an excellent game from an
intelligent team that is only beginning
to show its skill
[Music]
[Music]